GUIDELINES AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF GETTING THE VACCINE.
>> Harris: SENATOR TOM COTTON
IS ON DECK WITH US TODAY TO
WEIGH IN ON ALL OF IT.
HE WILL JOIN ME MOMENTS FROM
NOW.
FIRST LET’S GO STRAIGHT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
OUR CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
IS THERE WITH MORE ON THE TOP
STORY.
PETER.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS GOT WHAT THEY WANTED
AFTER SENDING THIS EMAIL TO THE
CDC THAT HAS NOW BEEN PUBLISHED
BY THE "NEW YORK POST" SAYING
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO SEE THE
INSERTION SOME VARIATION OF THE
FOLLOWING.
IN THE EVENT HIGH COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION RESULTS FROM A NEW
VARIANT OF SARS COVID 2 A NEW
UPDATE OF THE GUIDELINES MAY BE
NECESSARY AND THAT LAST PART IN
QUOTES WOUND UP IN THE OFFICIAL
CDC GUIDANCE.
RECORDS OF POLITICAL DONATIONS
FINDS THE AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND AFFILIATES
DONATED MILLIONS TO LIBERAL
GROUPS LAST CYCLE AND
LEADERSHIP CLAIMS THEY LOBBIED
TRUMP OFFICIALS MORE THAN BIDEN
OFFICIALS THIS YEAR WITH THIS
QUOTE.
WE REPRESENT 1.7 MILLION
EDUCATORS AND PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
SPENDING THE LAST 14 MONTHS
SERVING ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC AND WE
HAVE BEEN IN REGULAR TOUCH WITH
THE AGENCIES SETTING POLICIES
THAT AFFECTS THEIR WORK AND
LIVES INCLUDING THE CDC.
MOST STATES MOVED TEACHERS TO
THE FRONT OF THE LINE FOR
VACCINES MONTHS AGO BUT MANY
HAVE RESISTED GOING BACK SO FAR.
NOW REPUBLICANS ARE PRESSURING
THE PRESIDENT TO SEND THEM BACK.
>> ALL THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DO
IS STAND UP AND BE VERY FIRM.
THE TEACHERS AREN’T THE PROBLEM.
IT IS THEIR LEADERSHIP.
THE TEACHER UNIONS.
I THINK THE UNIONS ARE HOLDING
OUT FOR MORE PAY.
IN THE MEANTIME OUR CHILDREN
GET HURT AND WHAT IS SO
AVOIDABLE AND A SHAME ABOUT ALL
THIS IS PRESIDENT BIDEN CAN FIX
IT.
HE SAYS HE IS THE EDUCATION
PRESIDENT.
>> "NEW YORK TIMES" OPINION
PIECE MAKES THE CASE BECAUSE
SCHOOL REOPENINGS AFFECT
PARENTS ABILITY TO GO BACK TO
WORK AND PARENTING FALLS ON
WOMEN REOPENING COULD BECOME
THE BIGGEST GENDER EQUALITY
ISSUE OF THE YEAR.
>> Harris: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING IN SENATOR TOM
COTTON.
REPUBLICAN FROM ARKANSAS.
LET’S GET STARTED RIGHT THERE,
SENATOR.
YOU KNOW, IS THIS A CASE OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SIMPLY
COPYING THE HOMEWORK OF THE
TEACHERS UNION?
>> HARRIS, GOOD TO BE ON WITH
YOU.
THE CDC IS A THOROUGHLY
POLITICAL AGENCY.
MOST AMERICANS DISREGARD THEIR
ADVICE ON STEAKS, HAMBURGERS
AND BEER AND INCREASINGLY
DISREGARD THEIR ADVICE ON
SCHOOLS REOPENING.
THEY NEED TO BE OPEN.
WE’VE BEEN OPEN IN ARKANSAS
FIVE DAYS A WEEK IN PERSON
SINCE AUGUST.
LARGELY FINE AND THE CASE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS WELL.
WE SHOULDN’T HAVE A POLITICAL
BUREAUCRACIES ANSWERING TO THE
BECK AND CALL OF TEACHERS
UNIONS.
WE NEED KIDS BACK IN REAL
SCHOOL NOT A ZOOM SESSION WITH
TEACHERS NOT IN THE CLASSROOM.
WE NEED KIDS IN SCHOOLS WITH
THEIR TEACHERS NOW.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO
THIS.
IT HAS TO DO WITH THE MASK
WEARING.
WE’RE SEEING SOME OF THAT MIXED
MESSAGING FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AND HIM EVEN GETTING SPECIAL
TREATMENT, HE IS THE PRESIDENT,
THEY SAY.
MORE PROTECTION THAN THE REST
OF US WHO ARE FULLY VACCINATED.
MASKS HAVE BECOME A TOTEM IN
THE CULTURE WAR.
THERE IS NO VIR TRUE BEING
PERMANENTLY MASKED.
NO VIRTUE IN DEMANDING ZERO
RISK.
IF THERE WERE WE WOULD NEVER
JUMP IN A SWIMMING BAOL OR GET
INTO A CAR.
GET VACCINATED AND THEN GET
USED TO WEARING HARD PANTS,
BRUSHING YOUR HAIR AND TEETH
AND MEETING FRIENDS OUTSIDE OF
ZOOM.
SENATOR COTTON, YOUR REACTION.
>> DR. FAUCI SAYS WE NEED TO
KEEP WEARING MASKS INDEFINITELY.
HE ONCE AGAIN IS WRONG.
ALMOST HALF OF ALL AMERICAN
ADULTS ARE NOW VACCINATED AND
IT’S BEEN A COUPLE WEEKS SINCE
ALL AMERICANS BECAME ELIGIBLE.
BY THE END OF MAY ANYBODY WHO
WANTS A VACCINE WILL HAVE HAD A
CHANCE TO GET IT AND HAVE IT
BECOME FULLY EFFECTIVE.
ZERO REASON TO BE WEARING MASKS
OUTDOORS.
JOE BIDEN WHEN HE WALKS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TO THE MARINE
ONE HELICOPTER SHOULD TAKE OFF
HIS MASK AND SHOW AMERICANS
THAT IT IS FINE TO START
GETTING BACK TO NORMAL.
WE ARE INCREASINGLY REACHING
THE POINT WHERE PEOPLE ARE MORE
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING THE
VACCINE THAN THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT GETTING AN APPOINTMENT
FOR THE VACCINE.
ONE WAY TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
GET THE VACCINE WOULD SHOW ONCE
YOU HAVE IT YOU CAN GET BACK TO
YOUR NORMAL LIFE.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO WEAR A MASK,
OR KEEP SOCIAL DISTANCING.
GO BACK TO YOUR NORM’
PRE-CORONAVIRUS WAY OF LIFE AND
WHAT MOST AMERICANS ARE HOPING
FOR.
PEOPLE VACCINATED FULLY SHOULD
TAKE OFF THE MASKS AND GET BACK
TO NORMAL.
>> Harris: IT IS SO SIMPLE TO
HEAR YOU SAY IT AND SO SIMPLE
TO SEE THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
TEAM DO IT.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR HIS MASK
THAT HE TOOK OFF AND HE CAN’T
FIND.
I’M SURE YOU SAW THE VIDEO AND
EVERYBODY LOOKING HAS ON A MASK.
IT IS LIKE YOU WAY, WAY TO SELL
IT, NOT.
WE’LL MOVE ON.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN HITS THE
ROAD THIS WEEK, SENATOR HE IS
TRYING TO BUILD SUPPORT FOR HIS
MASSIVE SPENDING PLANS.
HILLARY CLINTON SAYS SHE IS
THRILLED HE IS TAKING HIS
AGENDA.
>> IT WASN’T UNTIL THE PANDEMIC
THAT I THINK A TRULY WORKING
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS CROSSING
PARTY LINES AS WE’VE SEEN
BECAUSE OF THE APPROVAL THAT
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS
ARE GIVING BIDEN, SUDDENLY
UNDERSTOOD IN A CLEAR WAY THAT,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THERE ARE LOTS OF TIMES WHEN WE
NEED THE GOVERNMENT.
>> Harris: THIS COMES 25 YEARS
AFTER HER HUSBAND, PRESIDENT
CLINTON, FAMOUSLY DECLARED THE
ERA OF BIG GOVERNMENT IS OVER.
WOW.
I HEAR MORE MIXED MESSAGING,
SENATOR.
>> HARRIS, IF HILLARY CLINTON
IS PRAISING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IT’S A SIGN
THEY’RE DOING SOMETHING WRONG.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED THE
GOVERNMENT.
TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS, TO STOP
ILLEGAL ALIENS FROM CROSSING AT
RECORD NUMBERS.
WHAT HAS JOE BIDEN DONE?
TOTALLY OPENED OUR BORDERS.
HE IS INSISTING THAT HIS PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES GET MORE AND
MORE MIGRANTS INTO THE COUNTRY
AS OPPOSED TO BORDER SECURITY
STOPPING THEM COMING IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND OUR GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO PROTECT CITIZENS FROM
CRIME.
JOE BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE TO ATTACK THE POLICE,
HIS DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
GOING ON WITCH HUNTS AGAINST
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO PASS
MORE LAWS IN CONGRESS TO LET
FELONS OUT OF PRISON EARLY.
THOSE ARE A COUPLE TIMES WHEN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EXPECT
THEIR GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT
THEM AND IT’S EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT JOE BIDEN AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
>> Harris: IT IS GREAT TO HAVE
YOU ON THE PROGRAM TODAY,
SENATOR AND VERY GLAD TO GET TO
THIS REAL QUICKLY.
A GROUP OF SENATE DEMOCRATS ARE
CALLING ON THE PRESIDENT TO
SHUT DOWN THE GUANTANAMO BAY
PRISON.
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S SECRETARY OF
STATE WAS ASKED ABOUT IT.
I CAN’T WAIT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
IT.
LET’S WATCH FIRST.
>> WILL THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CLOSE GUANTANAMO
BAY?
>> WE BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD BE.
THAT IS CERTAINLY A GOAL BUT IT
IS SOMETHING WE’LL BRING FOCUS
TO IN THE MONTHS AHEAD.
>> Harris: SENATOR, I KNOW YOU
HAVE SERVED, WE KNOW THAT.
WE CELEBRATE THAT SERVICE AND
THAT SACRIFICE WITH YOU ON THIS
PROGRAM ALL THE TIME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO WITH GITMO, WHAT COMES TO
MIND?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY WANT TO
TREAT THOSE GUANTANAMO BAY
TERRORISTS THE WAY THEY TREAT
THE MIGRANTS.
PROBABLY LET THEM IN AND OUT.
ONCE THEY GET ON AMERICAN SOIL
NO TELLING WHAT A BUNCH OF
LIBERAL LAWYERS WILL DO IN
COURT.
IF THE DEMOCRATIC SENATORS WANT
GUANTANAMO TERRORISTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
LET’S PUT THEM IN THEIR STATES.
>> Harris: SENATOR, IS THERE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF THIS
THAT MAYBE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ISN’T
TOUCHING ON?
>> THERE ARE MORE LEGAL RIGHTS
GRANTED TO THOSE TERRORISTS
ONCE THEY’RE ON THE AMERICAN
MAIN LAND SOIL.
NO TELLING WHAT THE LIBERAL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
LIBERAL JUDGES DO.
THE SAFEST PLACE IS GUANTANAMO.
IF IT WASN’T FOR LIBERAL JUDGES
INTERVENING THEY WOULD HAVE --
TERRORISM IS STILL A THREAT.
IF WE HAVE OPERATIONS WHERE WE
CAPTURE A LOT OF HIGH VALUE
TERRORISTS IN THE FUTURE, WHERE
WILL THEY PUT THEM?
BRING THEM TO THE UNITED STATES
OR SEND THEM TO SOME OTHER
COUNTRY WHERE THEY MAY NOT HAVE
THE PROTECTIONS THEY DO HAVE AT
GUANTANAMO?
GITMO IS A SUITABLE PLACE.
WE ARE DETAINING SOME OF THE
WORLD’S MOST DANGEROUS
TERRORISTS.
THAT’S WHERE THEY SHOULD STAY
AND FUTURE DETAINEES SHOULD GO.
>> Harris: NOTHING RECRUITS
LIKE PEOPLE INSIDE THE GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD HAVING
THAT SORT OF LIBERAL ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THEM.
THEY CAN TALK, THEY CAN
PROSELYTIZE.
>> I SAW THAT WAS THE CASE WITH
THE BLIND SHEIK IN THE FIRST
TRADE CENTER BOMBING.
HE REMAINED AN ACTIVE
PROSELYTIZEER FROM FEDERAL
PRISON IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Harris: SENATOR COTTON.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TODAY.